today's show is all about hard
conversations
we talked to a woman whose friend's son
committed suicide and she doesn't know
what to say
we talked to a woman who has a disabled
son who's facing an uncertain future
we talk to a young college student who's
a muslim who's facing ugly
discrimination
and he doesn't know what to do next stay
tuned
[Applause]
hey what's up everybody this is john
with the dr john dolone show
the show i named after myself because
why not that's how low my self-esteem
is i hope y'all are doing well hope your
friends are doing well and families are
doing well you're staying healthy
and getting ready for whatever comes
next in your world on this show we talk
about your mental health your wellness
what's going on in your life with your
kids with the person that you love
the person you used to love who doesn't
love you anymore anything you want to
talk about
give me a call at 1-844-693-3291 that's
six 1-844-690 three three two nine one
or you can go to johndaloni.com
show fill out the form and kelly
will decide your fate so
a couple of things i wanna do before we
get the show roland we got a packed
house today number one
please please please send me
your success stories send me
shout outs to the teacher who made a big
deal made an impact on your life
send me about that husband who has just
been stepping up that boyfriend who you
didn't think he had it in him
and he does to that mom who is cranking
out
on little to no sleep who is working
hard who is
loving life to that dad who called you
and said
i'm sorry i screwed up and i want to
make our relationship
right to that mom who's just kept
chipping away
let me know i want to read i want to put
some more positivity out into the world
we talk about a lot of hard and heavy
things on this show and i want to
continue to be a voice for positivity
and also we are
this is what show 88 89 90 something
like that i want to take a quick second
to say
thanks to my man zac b james c
even kelly thank you all for
teaching me helping me figure this out
and for dressing up so nicely
back there man you guys sure know how to
put on the suit in time
hey i showered today no
for those of you listening on podcast
the face
as i watched the the things james is
going to respond to
scroll through his mind and they all
went nope that'll get us cancelled nope
that'll get us canceled that'll get me
fired
i'm just gonna sit here in silence
that's what wisdom looks like good folks
and you all missed it
i got it but man that guy sure loves
wearing t-shirts and a hat to work so
to all you guys wearing your suits and
ties
shirt at least buttons up kelly all
right let's go to uh christy in
jacksonville florida let's get the calls
going today
christy what's going on welcome to the
show how can i help
um so a hello by the way hello
we start this show with greetings so
good
good good to talk to you christy what's
going on um
my closest girlfriend and her husband
just lost uh her son due to uh mental
health
did he take his life he did
i hate that hate that hate that the
nuance to it
is it happened a week prior to them
moving into our house
um he was in mid-20s
okay but they were in the process of
moving
um they're being they're having a house
being built so they were moving into our
house
and you know just dealing with moving
and trying to
feel bad stressful enough of course and
moving with your friends
but you know that happening a week prior
it sort of changed the dynamic of
what to expect you know we are very sort
of it changed everything
yeah yeah you know the four of us are
really really close
and which is why of course we offered
for them to come and stay with us
right for the next few months and
i am trying to help her navigate
all of that and i and be her support and
i
i'm not really i don't i've never really
dealt with
death besides grandparents and you know
my father passed away i was really young
but as an adult i don't know i don't
know what to say or how to
how to help gosh christy thank you for
calling
um number one i absolutely hate that for
your friends i hate that for you guys i
hate that for that young man
that's gonna ripple through that family
system for a long long long time
right and it may not feel like it but
they could not have had a better
situation to run into that
that buzz solve of of pain
to be able to come live with two people
that
loved loved them so much that y'all
opened your home to them before this
even happened right
um so this happened about a week ago
week before they moved in with you a
week before they moved in with us it's
been a few weeks
and how long have they been with you a
couple weeks okay
so behind closed doors i i've i've dealt
with this so much and so i'll walk you
through here's some things to do
and we'll speak broadly to people who
love love others who are in pain
but how has this affected you and your
husband
we're good you know we've always had a
really close really strong relationship
um and so have they which helps you know
we are all like-minded in that
fashion um it has helped us with them
moving in it has helped us communicate
better you know you have to communicate
well when you have
other people living in your house so it
has rippled
to him and i which has only strengthened
things so that's awesome that's so good
um that's it generally barbells that way
it either draws people closer together
and those scales and drama just melt
right or
people grieve so differently that it
becomes a source of
of deep tension and it just exposes
cracks that were already there so that's
really great what has it been like
having that couple live with you how
have they been navigating the world
um pretty good you know the first two
weeks
there were days that you know the house
is divided
to two separate kind of master bedroom
bathroom areas so
they have their space and we have ours
and then the living room is
common ground so there are days that
i don't see her because she needs to
grieve in in
privacy and i understand that and
there's other days that
she will come out and you know make
dinner with us or you know be a part of
the family unit and then the husband
is supporting her and encouraging her
but also recognizing when she needs the
space he will either
leave the house or come you know
socialize with that gotcha
so the couple of big overarching things
is there is not a right way for them to
handle this
and one of the most devastating things a
couple can do to each other
is to expect each other to grieve in
certain ways
that makes the other person feel
comfortable and
another devastating thing people can do
is to impose their pain
their discomfort on grieving people
right
so the way you just explained it to me
is so beautiful
sounds like she's got people in her
immediate area that love her
and love her enough to invite her to
make dinner you're not making it weird
and love her enough that she's not
coming out she's not coming out
and she has a husband that is gets that
too right
and my guess is he's gone into overdrive
and will
slowly have to deal with his own things
later there are some folks
that they just don't grieve like other
people do
and they don't need to fall down and cry
and they grieve internally
gently the way i like to explain is some
people
have a have a balloon of grief and it
just pops and it goes everywhere and
over time they've got to
slowly put those pieces back together
and some just gently let that air out of
that thing over time
and it just they they agree with it in
their own way there's not a right way to
do this
what i will tell you is no matter how
real
they look how much like your old friends
they look
being a couple of weeks out of losing
their son in that way
they are still grieving deeply they're
still in shock
and so um understand they're gonna
continue to come
in and out various in various ways over
the next six
months to a year okay here's a couple of
big rules
number one talk openly
not shamefully and directly and
compassionately don't beat around the
bush
okay um and and i'm not imposing this on
you i'm speaking this to the listening
audience
and also to you too hiding it and
talking in hush tones or in weird words
doesn't help
right so if it does come up and you are
invited into a conversation
you can say the words i'm so sorry your
son took his life
i'm so sorry that your son died by
suicide
right um i'm so sorry that happened
hiding it and talking in those elevated
weird distant
i'm sorry that there was a tragedy of
such heightened
right we try to we try to not say the
thing and we end up talking around it
and everybody just
doesn't have their pain met right they
don't they don't feel connected to
so just be open about it number two be
invited into those conversations
let them know that you're a safe place
let them know they can talk to you about
anything
if you're comfortable with that you
don't have to become a dumping ground
you can say hey i don't have any
resources
here to help you i'm happy to listen but
if you're okay
listening tell them that anytime
i i'm happy to be invited in that
conversation but don't force them to
help you feel better right um
let them know that you care about them
that you're willing to listen
but also be completely comfortable in
silence
and this is where i failed people in my
life and i had to learn this the hard
hard way
i read all the books i read all of the
things
i always wanted to know the quote
unquote right thing to say
and it took me sitting with person after
person after person whose child had died
by suicide
person after person whose child had
passed away in a car wreck or whose
spouse i realized oh gosh
there's nothing to say the most
therapeutic healing thing
in this moment is my presence that i'm
just here
and that's why i tell you you are such
you and your husband are such a
gift christy to this family because
you're just there
you're just there making dinner letting
the routine of life go on
they're anchored into that and then they
can repel off and grieve as they need to
remember this christy you're not trying
to fix them or
solve anything you're just simply being
with them
because you can't solve or fix this it
is a it's a permanent
thing it's a permanent wound right so
all of your focus can be
how can i be with them right so when
y'all are making dinner
is it like old times is there that
tension tell me about how that's going
for y'all
no it's it's been good
and i have to remind myself
that she still is in this process she's
very very strongly or both very very
strong and you know a tv show will be on
and um death will be depicted or suicide
will be depicted and
i immediately look to her because i
don't want to make her uncomfortable
yeah
um and sometimes she says it
it's too much right now and we turn it
off or you know we
you know whatever is appropriate in that
time
so that's been good it's just for me
reminding myself that she is going
through this because
she she's really really strong
did her son struggle with mental illness
for a long long time has this been an in
and out kind of thing or was it a total
surprise
yes no it's it's okay
so they may have been grieving this for
years
right and they're gonna agree this final
resolution all i have to say is it's
gonna look different
some a great gift you can give somebody
who's standing in your house is to hand
them the remote
and say you control this you turn it off
whenever anything
pops up that gets weird right or at any
moment we're defaulting back to leslie
knope
and or the office right at any moment
we're gonna roll back to that
you but you control this remote right
and they may roll their eyes back i
don't need to do that whatever they're
gonna need it at some point
those can be one of those gifts um it
does feel real and it is real
don't feel like you're living in the
matrix right it is real it is connected
there but it's gonna fade in and out my
guess is a year from now two years from
now
she may not remember a lot of the the
details that you're gonna remember
really vividly
what she's gonna remember is that
christy and her husband were there
they showed up you didn't say anything
dumb like
god got another angel or why did he do
this you didn't say anything stupid you
were about focusing on them and just
being with them so anybody listening
there's a tragedy if there is a
um someone you love has someone who dies
so someone you love does something
stupid they cheat and get kicked out of
med school they
what speak less
speak less don't try to solve it be
invited into the solution part of it
speak less and just seek to be with them
just be with them just be
with them and you're gonna say no dude
forget your feelings bro
facts are your friends i say factor your
friends all the time it gets misapplied
sometimes
it's not about solving people it's not
about trying to fix them they need to
get up and get going
be with them encourage them every day
hey i'm going for a walk you want to
come i'm going for a walk you want to
come
they can say no they can say no is there
a time and a place for getting somebody
to bed yes
that's not two weeks after their son
takes their life right
and you will get some wisdom along the
way there christy i am grateful for you
and your family that's awesome give me a
call back in a couple of weeks if things
get
start to shake a little bit or if your
friend
they want to give me a call i'd love to
talk to them too they can they can be
a shine a light on families who are
struggling all across this country
about what it's like to be on the other
side of this this awful awful situation
but
i'm glad you're in the universe christy
you and your husband all are good good
people
all right let's go to uh lisa in atlanta
georgia lisa what's going on
hey dr john i just want to thank you for
your show i know you helped so many
people
um and we have a son who's profoundly
disabled okay
and you know throughout his life we've
just kind of met
step by step what we need to do for him
and
now we're getting older i'm in my 60s
and so we're facing that
i kind of call it the final challenge
where we have to
you know find i'm going to start crying
already that's okay it's all right this
one's heavy
trying to you know find a place for him
when we're gone
yep and that's my my
problem right now is i you know like
we've
gotten guardianship of him and we've got
a special needs trust for him and we've
taken care of our wills and um we even
took care of our funerals and all those
things and so now this is like okay now
we need to start finding a place um
first of all that will accept him
he's profound so there's not a lot of
choices
and um so i'm just trying to and i know
there's lots of other moms that will
are dealing with this as well so i just
kind of don't know the steps to
prepare myself for you know taking him
there and walking away one day
or um and also for him you know how do
we
tell the kids you know we have to take
you this place one day yeah does he
does he have the cognitive capacity to
understand that conversation
i i know i'm quite sure he doesn't okay
he's profoundly um you know the best
they could tell maybe like a two to
three year old level
okay maybe um but
he does know you know he knows us he's
been loved his whole life
he goes with us where we go you know and
he just wouldn't i can't even think if
he wasn't taken care of you know and
yeah
you just hear all those horror stories
of people in nursing homes and things
that happen and i just yeah
but there are also some really great
ones right you know that yeah you know
that yeah
hey this is this isn't a data
conversation this is a mom and a baby
boy conversation right
right right um so let's clear the
the the big piece let's clear the clear
the the most important thing nobody
will ever love that little boy like you
do ever
right right right and
he won the freaking lottery
when he got you as his mom
thank you i won two how old is he
he's 29. 29. he
won he won
he got you which is so cool lisa
um so i wish i could help here
there is no way there's no
preparatory thing there's no exercise
program or yoga class you can take
to make that singular drop-off
easy yeah it's not
it's going to be real real hard and
it's going to be right you know what i
mean
yeah i mean it has to have to be it has
to be right
and there will get to be a moment when
not that someone's ever going to out
love you
no chance will anyone out love you but
there will come a time
when somebody has more skills more
um technology more mobility
that can help him serve him better than
you can
and that's okay great with you right
right and you can sleep and not knowing
i out love all those suckers
they can pick him up and move him and
take care of his needs
i always love him more so haha right all
that's going to be true
and one of the deep deep deep pains deep
pains
of loving somebody who's with a profound
disability
is um and it's the same it's it's
similar as you mentioned to navigating
life with a child right when a child's
got to go in for some sort of treatment
you can't explain what
why this pain is this way i remember
lisa i remember
her the first time my first little boy i
was trying to be super dad and i'm not
going to be like the other dads i'm
going with all these new appointments
and i took my little and he may have
been six months and my wife was with me
she by the way knew this was happening
and i didn't
we took him in and this to this doctor's
office we're hugging and playing
and he's cooing and this angel of death
came in
with two two uh syringes
like two giant needles in my head
they're like nine inches long they
probably weren't
and she double blasted him in each leg
same time cacao
and he looked at me like dad
you like you're that old like a2 brute
like
you yeah you and then he screamed i
still have that scream in my soul
i have not gone back my wife said you're
not welcome back because
i wanted to take that nurse and oh it
was not going to end well
right here's the thing you can't explain
it
it's a it's a it's the thing that has to
happen
and it's hard because love sucks
sometimes
right right right the price of love is
that pain
and what you're going to have to
constantly pull yourself back to it's
the same thing you've had to do your
whole life right have you struggled with
bouts of guilt throughout your life
no i really have it good for you dude
you're
you're already a gangster lisa that's
awesome
man one of the most common things when i
talk to parents of special needs kids is
that
that guilt like somehow you know this is
on me right
good for you that's awesome so yeah
here's what you need to do you need to
prep for this moment how soon is it
how soon are you thinking about a home
one so i mean i just i just
you know i think it was you know two
like two weeks ago we just went ahead
and got our funerals all planned and
you know paid for and taken care of and
i started thinking
you know um i really need to start
getting him
you know start thinking of that because
i know there's waiting lists and
especially for the good places and so i
need to start making those phone calls
and i
picked up the phone to call a place his
caseworker had said would
would be a a good nursing home and i
just started crying
but i'll call you back hey and you know
what that that happens
that happens all the time yeah it does i
want you and your husband to read a book
together
called finding finding meaning by david
kessler
we'll link to it in the show notes here
it's a book on grief
but more importantly it's a book on what
happens on the other side of grief
and david kessler is the is the guru
when it comes to grieving
and the the book not to spoil alert here
but he has he's been the guy who's
called into
to hard situations forever that's just
been his thing he's the guy he was
studied under elizabeth kubler-ross he's
the guy
and then he lost his
20-something-year-old son
and a profound moment in the book is
when he talks about i want to go back
and hug
every parent i ever talked to about
grief because i had no idea
right but then he talks on the back end
of finding meaning so what are some
things when you can't lift your son
anymore
when you can't get him up the ramp
anymore when you can't feed him
in the way that he needs to be taken
care of anymore and you've got to
surrender that service part not the love
but surrender that service part to
somebody else where will you then find
meaning
how extraordinary would it be if you
opened up a free service because it
sounds like you guys have taken care of
your finances
in a way that is really gonna honor your
son honor your your last years
what if you open up a free service to
talk to new moms
and dads who just found out they are
giving birth to a son or a daughter with
profound needs
what if you led a small group to walk
moms and dads what this is going to be
like
and suddenly that angst you feel that
somebody else is caring for your son
doing those things that you've spent the
last 30 years doing
you're able to channel that into serving
new families who are going to be walking
this journey that you and your husband
have walked so carefully and so well
and that's just one example that came to
me off top of my head but
it becomes about when you're 65 and 70
and 75 and 80 and 85
how are you going to make meaning of
that hurt how are you going to make
meaning of that loss of connection there
and how are you going to continue to
honor your son and love your son
in just a new and unique way right but
you're doing all the right things
there's not an easy way to drive away
there's not
there's not an easy way to explain to
somebody with with limited cognitive
capacity
that this is the best right thing even
though it's gonna be hard
even though you know he's gonna to be
with you
even though you know he recognizes you
it's going to be hard
you and your husband are going to need
need each other and then you're going to
need to go make meaning
you're going to need to let meaning come
to you and
you're talking about legacy changing
family tree changing meaning when you
get involved in the lives of other folks
in that way so
thank you for your heart lisa i wish i
could just snap my fingers and make it
happen
but oh man all right let's go um
oh that's tough all right let's take one
more call here let's go to
mo in charleston south carolina mo
what's going on brother
hey mr john and lenny what's up dude
hey man how can i help uh
well i'm having a problem just with me
being muslim and you know being
outwardly muslim you know
as in just my appearance where i wear a
koopa at
like uh as a recently like i've been
having problems where i
pray outside for lunch or something and
people drive by and throw bottles at me
and call me you know
saying saying derogative words you know
like
i'm saying this yeah i know it's i'm 21
and
i've been dealing with it my whole life
and it hasn't been this bad ever since i
moved
to south carolina 10 months ago and i
just don't know if i even want to
deal with it anymore bro i'm sorry man
i was like i don't man i hate that for
you
i hate that for you you don't deserve
that man i'm glad you're a part of our
communities i hate that you're
experiencing that
what are you doing in south carolina
what are you there for uh i'm going to
school
going to school um is this happening on
campus or is this just a part of making
your way through that community
mostly out of campus when i go to work
okay
man
man you broke my heart mo and i'm not
the one hurting here so i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna take your story from you
but
man i i hate that you're experiencing
that i hate that people are so
ignorant and stupid and repulsive that
they would treat another person like
that
especially someone who's simply trying
to express their faith
in a gentle way i hate it um
so i wish i could tell you that i
haven't worked at college campuses where
i've had to have this conversation with
students in your situation before but i
have
um at the end of the day the most you
can do is take care of you
right and if somebody's throwing bottles
at you obviously that's a crime
right that's a criminal act and i hope
that you're in a situation where you're
safe enough to get the authorities
involved in that
um but i know that's easier said than
done right and
yeah it's kind of like it happened like
when i was praying so i
couldn't even get my eyes on them i mean
yeah
so here's the deal you got to find
people you can be safe with
okay you got if you're not safe or if
your professors are out of bounds i'm
going to tell you something crazy
um you've got it you've got to be safe
or you can't do the things to learn
right you've got to be safe or you can't
fully express your faith
if you've got to be safe or you can't
connect with other people where you're
going to find
your future spouse where you're going to
find your community right
and over time when those things happen
in a concentrated area like that you say
it
has never happened like this right
people have run their mouth
my whole life i've lived in new york i
mean virginia and it's
i've never experienced this amount of
blatant racism
strictly to my face man
ever so hey
what do you want to be when you grow up
ma'am a
engineer a civil engineer oh you mean
you want to help bridges and roads so
people can get to work and go see their
kids
yes sir what a jerk dude what a jerk moe
unbelievable why did you say that why
did you give me a job that
is going to be dedicated to service of
others you know why because you're a
good person brother
god that pisses me off man exactly
i can go real quick from heartbroken to
real pissed off fast and i don't get mad
very often man but you got my heart all
riled up
listen um yeah i mean even my best
friends who are christians
even they try to help me out here and
then but it's like when i get caught off
guard
by myself it's it's a lot you know and i
i try my best not to fight
or get angry or aggressive but it just
when it keeps on happening it's like if
there's a test or
i don't know i want you to protect your
heart man
i want you to protect your heart and if
that means
leaving school leaving that area and
going to some place that's going to
honor you and your faith and that might
be what you have to do
um this is going to sound crazy i've
been in a place that
was not appreciative of my faith and i
ended up taking out and going somewhere
else okay um yeah
i also don't want to encourage people
who are i don't want to encourage that
type of blatant racism man
and so it's easy for me as a privileged
guy to sit on the outside and say
well here's what you should be doing you
know what i mean um yeah
at the end of the day you've got to be
safe and you've got to find people who
care and love for you and your heart and
your heart of service
you know what i mean you deserve that
and i
hate the fact that people in our
community
and my region of the country are
treating you like that
right what i don't want you to do and
this is gonna sound trivial and i've got
no
man what i'm gonna tell you is gonna
sound so trite and so silly and so
privileged and so i'm gonna apologize on
the front end but i mean it from the
bottom of my heart
i don't want the ignorance and idiocy
and stupidity of a few
to sour your heart to change your spirit
and to begin to shift your default
setting to
not one of love and peace and compassion
and service to other people but one of
anger and hate okay
and i want you to know i'm gonna do what
i can as a part of
my community to speak loudly and boldly
from the inside out on how we treat
people who are different than us and
look different than us and pray
different than us
and also i want you to make sure you
protect and take care of your heart and
soul
yes sir right
yeah you deserve better than this i i
need you
making good roads for that my kids are
going to drive on okay
i need you dedicating your life to
fixing all the buildings that are
falling i don't know whatever civil
engineers do but i just know that my
kids need you
okay i need you okay yes sir
you got it yes sir thank you
so whatever you got to do to make sure
you got people you can be safe with
people that will rally around you maybe
it's getting a group of
call your christian friends on the
carpet say i'm going out to pray
and i want you all to pray with me it's
going to look different
yeah come with me right
you know um it may be it may be she got
to leave man and i hate that i hate that
for you i hate that for your school
community and hate that
for me my mom been talking about it she
wants me to leave but i just i just i
i kind of want to just try to finish the
semester out but i got you i got you
yeah
that's brave but take care of your heart
okay all right
talk to the people at your school too
let them know what you're going through
make sure you are meeting with people
on campus and let them know what you're
experiencing sometimes college campuses
i've
i've had myself i've been called on the
carpet on this um
college folks have partnerships with
local police they have partnerships with
local
churches local schools and um
sometimes it's the school's
responsibility to get involved in making
sure that there's a safe educational
environment for their students
right all right and um i love you man
i'm glad that you're
out there going to school to serve other
people and um
keep yourself safe okay if that means
you gotta go you gotta go
cali stop everybody
quit ignorant
stupid morons throwing bottles at people
man
let people pray in peace for crying out
loud let people dress how they want to
dress for crying out loud
it's freaking ridiculous man stop
stop and if you see that nonsense in
your friend group
cut it out cut it out
if you hear somebody in your friend
group talking like an idiot cut it out
tell them to stop none of this crap
stops
until people in the majority say enough
we're done with it we're gonna let
people be now we're not only gonna let
people
be we're gonna love people because i
need more civil engineers you know what
they're doing
i need more everybody i don't care what
their outcome is that made me sound like
i just want to love people because of
what they're gonna
do for us no i love people because
they're worth loving
drives me crazy i'm gonna wrap this show
up before i
just lose my just kind of money all
right so as we
i'm trying not to make a horse noise
trying hard
trying hard not to make a horse noise i
just i'm flexing and i got a big shirt
on i don't have big muscles and so on a
flex it looks weird
makes everybody uncomfortable the whole
thing all right so as i wrap up today's
show
this is a perfect song it may not be but
i don't know it's from the 1995 record
the benz
one of the awesomest bands of all time
radiohead
from their just a remarkable record if
you got one record to go listen to today
listen to
the benz by radiohead listen to it all
the way through it's incredible
song's called high and dry and it goes
like this two jumps in a week
i bet you think that's pretty clever
don't you boy flying on your motorcycle
watching all the ground beneath you drop
you kill yourself for recognition kill
yourself to never ever stop you broke
another mirror
you're turning into something you're not
don't leave me high
don't leave me dry don't leave me high
and don't leave me dry it's the best
thing you've ever had it's the best
thing that you've ever had
don't leave me high and dry this has
been the dr john
deloney show take care of each other out
there
jeez louise
you